[Musique]
on approche du premier anniversaire de
l'arrivée du convoi des camionneurs à
Ottawa à la fin janvier et un des
organisateurs du convoi James Bauer
planifie déjà l'édition 2023 qui devrait
avoir lieu du 17 au 20 février même si
le premier à une version écourtée et un
rassemblement manifestant à l'extérieur
du centre-ville certains s'inquiètent ça
me stresse
c'était pas c'était pas joli la dernière
fois le député furgus espère que les
leçons du passé serviront
une belle coordination entre nos
services policiers pour s'assurer la
sécurité des gens justement la
conseillère à la sécurité nationale et
au renseignements auprès du Premier
ministre Justin Trudeau affirme que des
conseillers principaux se rencontrent
pour planifier la réaction du
gouvernement à la venue de nouveaux
convois lors d'une comparution devant le
comité mixte spécial jeudi tormus a dit
que plusieurs au fonctionnaires se sont
rencontrés cette semaine
le secrétaire adjoint au Bureau du
Conseil privé soutient que les autorités
ont déjà modifié leur approche face aux
manifestations
comme lors du Rolling Stones inspiré du
convoi des camionnettes et que bien des
choses ont changé depuis février
mais précise surveiller continuellement
les événements à venir qui pourraient
avoir des répercussions dans la ville
j'aime la voix
plus préparé que la dernière fois
certainement
c'était vraiment plus qu'une menace pour
le monde qui vivent ici la vague
gouvernement ça devrait être la sécurité
publique qui devrait avoir appris
j'imagine de ce qui s'est produit et je
pense que ces gens-là si on peut compris
le message de la population canadienne
je pourrais ce qu'on va faire je pense
qu'on a beaucoup appris je m'attends à
ce que les outils que dans les corps
policiers disposent soient mises en
place pour assurer qu'on n'est pas une
répétition de l'occupation qui a fait
mal énormément de gens
peu importe la manifestation il sera
difficile d'accéder à la rue Wellington
qui demeure complètement enfermé à la
circulation et dont la réouverture n'est
pas prévu de si tôt c'est une carothawa
on ne veut pas revivre les événements de
l'hiver dernier ici Frédéric pépère
Radio-Canada
Ottawa